you
a split blame to any any any any other
country what we're about our blame
I mean who did they what what country
did they flee they flirt did they flood
the United States they I mean they flirt
on some other they fled our country it
is it is our fault we haven't been able
to provide anything not a decent job not
a decent school the real fact is that
yes I do condemn the treatment of our
migrants in the United States in Mexico
and what Ramallah but I really I really
I really will say to the people of our
country that we have to focus and make
our country better and make our country
a place where nobody has to have to my
grandma I think my greatest is a right
but it should be an option not an
obligation the best thing that we can do
is to fix the problems that have made
that have made our people to flee in a
Sabha the authority for population one
third of our population lives abroad one
third that's just compared to countries
that have the rare in war or there are
or there they may have a contrary status
sometimes we don't see the pictures
sometimes we don't see the videos but
they try to distill their